and then when they get it they don't
want it anymore and and that's something
that i've seen as a man
throughout my whole entire life like a
woman will tell you that they actually
want something like they want this
nice guy or they want this thing and
then they get it and they're like
it's a bit too
nice guys we wouldn't hate that
balance we don't like too sweet or too
too how you say um player you know we
like player and we like sweet it's like
a mix you know you need to mix otherwise
it's going to be too boring or too
how do you say too traumatized because
players you know they can be a bit
narcissist and they can be a bit
traumatic so it's a bit it's about a mix
about balance if you are too much this
or too much that of course we get it
like ah
okay so can i say as a man right that
that perfect balanced man that you're
looking for doesn't exist i know and so
you
you having that in your head and i think
that's a lot of time why women get
disappointed with men because they've
created this actual man in their head
that actually doesn't exist right and so
you're looking for this man and you
think oh that's the one that's like he
doesn't exist no woman has found the
quote-unquote perfect man yet they're
looking for him though and i think
that's because you guys have been sold a
disney version of what um relationships
are you know like um men per there are
just good men or or and good women right
out there and i think that this whole oh
a man should be this we want this we
want that he's got to be he's got to
have an edge to him but then he's got to
be nice and he's got to be loyal but
then he's got to be a homemaker but then
he can't be tuned out is that it's like
how this list is like how long what what
is this list how it is the list
from men about women
our list is very simple
tell us
don't talk too much
okay be cooperative
uh
be a good mother if you if you got if
you've got children
um
and and cooperate like me talk too much
what the hell because because we don't
because men like peace so
no women don't like these traumas women
don't like peace i don't i i generally
don't think women like peace i think
once women get peace they get bored i
think women like excitement
yeah i think they like something a
little bit like a little bit more edgy a
little bit more exciting because if you
give a woman if you give a woman too
much peace she's like oh this is a
little bit boring whereas men will be
happy to be bored for the rest of their
life chill with a woman have this woman
as their woman and be like all right
cool this is my woman for the rest of
her life did you know women only swipe
right between five and fifteen percent
of the time on dating apps where men
swipe right fifty to sixty percent of
the time
why do you think that is
why because women have have to be more
selective we carry a kid for nine months
so it's like in our dna in my opinion
where men were more programmed to like
spread their seed and like women have a
long list of requirements typically as
that prerequisites which sometimes are
probably unreasonable
yeah i think women get disappointed by
their own
by their own um expectations
expectations yes and i think your ex i
think women's expectations are quite
deluded if i'm totally honest i think
it's like you get i i've known a few
women who have said oh i wanted this guy
and i got with him but he was too nice i
said but you said you wanted a nice guy
yeah but he was too what the that's too
nice to me what do you mean what do you
mean yeah he was just a bit boring it
was a bit squared he didn't have any
like edge to him it's like
that is why when women go for these
quote-unquote dogs they have that
excitement they have that that that
spice to them they have that edge to
them and then when that man acts the way
he's supposed to act as that type of guy
you get disappointed you're like he's a
dog he's like no well you picked him you
picked him because you saw that edge in
him i agree with that yeah i think
there's like extreme there's like the
two sweet guy
and there is like the one
the player the excitement that there is
like i i never met a guy that has both
i've mentioned a guy that has very sweet
that was my seven year uh relationship
my ex and then i met another guy for a
year and a half
and he gave me all that excitement and
then trauma
and right still healing
right this is not me normal so why did
you so with this episode if you don't
mind me asking so the seven year guy
what was bad about that like was he what
was bad about that relationship
he's a great guy like when it comes to
heart like he's a great human
you know is he has a good heart i just
feel like he would make me jealous on
purpose like in front of me i don't know
why you know like i was like what the
[ __ ] i feel like it was probably
insecure
um and that's your problem and if you
want to talk about it let's talk about
i'm i'm here to listen but i'm not here
to experience your pain or triggering
your frustrations you know if you get
triggered don't put it on me
um so yeah he was making me jealous and
then on my birthday for example i
actually got traumatized because
uh honestly
so he was next to me and a girl was next
to him
and
he was talking to her i don't mind talk
who the [ __ ] you want
but then he was putting sounded like you
minded
i'm not gonna lie it sounded like you
did mine because that's what i'm telling
you right now is because he was talking
to her and he was putting his hand on
her leg and it was like glue on his hand
he didn't just touch and you know took
off it just let his hand there like had
glue for five minutes and then i pinched
myself and on my birthday i just felt
like
what the [ __ ]
you know
sorry
oh sorry
wow
i didn't mean to like make you tell that
story and like get upset
they are
anyway
so yeah it's my birthday you know it's
your day it's a day that you cannot
forget you know because you're gonna
always remember
and
[Music]
it's hard when
it's
situations like that that
make you
think about
just other situations because seven
years is a long time
and
if i were you i'd be like i'm for the
streets too forget him i'm out here
i'm gonna go around and find something
better so
it's
it's hard to want to
find the person that
you you want and you have these things
and you essentially get that person
but they
it's is what you want but at the end
it's like not what you want you're like
i never i never thought that that person
would have done that but it's like we
we cast our vision on what we
um
what we what we want but we don't see
past it's like our hand is like our hand
is our vision but we can't see past our
hand because our hands in the way and
what what they really are is behind our
hand but we don't move it because like
this is what i want this is what i see
and i want this but what they really are
is behind it and i feel like we as women
have
have standards which we should for
ourselves
but it's so
astronomical that we're not able to
really see who a person is so stuff like
that happens because we have these
standards and this image of who we want
in our lives that we can't see the
reference or we see them but we don't we
don't acknowledge them or we don't um
say anything about we brush it off like
oh
it was just plain they were just funny
but in the end it's like man
what is it that us as women really want
do we all want men that are over six
foot
or do we really want someone that is no
matter how boring they are that is going
to
care for us in those
days where we should if we should be
celebrated and that aren't going to step
out or not going to do things that they
know are going to hurt us
yeah definitely
but that was not my relationship with
seven years that i had with my ex that
was the relationship there recently for
a year okay okay yeah because that was
the extreme the player that i was
talking and the other one that was so
sweet so loyal so good because there are
good really good ones out there
that was with the seven years yeah i
just broke up with him because i moved
to london and i was doing switzerland
with him yeah
uh but yeah definitely i agree with that
why didn't you marry him then you would
here for seven years because i don't
want to marry you no i don't want to
marry now i want to have a family i want
to marry but i want to take care of my
mom first my mom is my baby
so i want to because on my career and i
want to provide for me and for my mom
and then
you know get married and get a family
okay that's my plan
yeah
what if
and
i i hope like you don't feel like the
spotlight's on you this is like just a
general question if anybody was in that
situation that had to take care of a
parent what if there was someone that
came into your life that was like i will
stand behind you no matter what it is
that you have to do and i will be there
for you to help you take care of your
mother whatever it is no matter if i'm
here if i'm away would you reconsider
like if your
boyfriend for seven years was like i'll
move to london with you i will help you
take care of your mother like i'm here
for the long run would you have
stayed with him
yes but he didn't want to
he didn't want to move to london because
he came here though to experience the
life and he didn't like you think he
thought he was too
chaos chaotic
thank you
yeah it is understandable because in
switzerland it's very peaceful it's very
organized israel is one of the most
amazing countries to live when it comes
to family you know low crime as well i
think yeah yeah it's very safe it's
when it comes to lifestyle is very
luxury even like for example for a
cleaner she gets like five thousand a
month you know and you can save because
you travel
so it is pretty clean it's pretty you
know
respectful towards people towards nature
towards animals you can get even your
dog to the restaurant to the supermarket
everything you know so it's pretty good
and they have the best schools and all
that and he kind of like want that for
his future and for his family and i
respect that so i had to you know get
what i want and he i respect like i wish
him the best honestly
so to get what he wants
you know so yeah i just feel like when
he comes
to get married and all that if even if i
have a guy in the future
telling me that he would be able to
help me i think i would be scared
because i'm very used to being
independent since i was younger since i
was like a child since i was like 10.
i was i was i had to take care of me and
my mom so i just feel if i have someone
now to take care
of me and my mom
i feel
it's abusive like i'm taking an
advantage i don't know i just feel like
i don't know
i'm not used to it i just don't like it
um do you ever like
like do you ever worry about running out
of time to get married like it might be
harder if you wait longer
i thought about that too
i'm like that's funny especially if you
want to have like a family and stuff
yeah but i'm very spiritual i i believe
in a lot a lot about the law of
attraction and about
you attract the people that you need to
attract at certain moment to
learn certain types of lessons and i
think the right if you are not in a fear
place
above that if you let go
yeah i think you're going to meet the
right person at the right time and
things will suddenly happen because
there's amazing stories out there it's
not from disney no but there's like uh
stories of i mean real stories out there
that i seen couples getting married and
getting a family later on you know even
early
so
there's a bit of
everything i feel i think we just are
putting people in boxes and realities
they are limited
like probably uk realities
but you realize like 50 of women over 30
are single and childless
so there's a lot more um cases where it
didn't work out than it did
so this manifestation thing
can i just like bring it back like this
whole manifestation law of attraction
thing
sounds great um on paper but
statistically when you look at it like
pearl said like over 30 and you're less
likely to like get married and stuff
like that and the thing is um as a man
it's very interesting that um
i think like echo chambers are a thing
like so
i think when
one of the reasons why
men get um like attacked
when
they speak the truth about statistics is
because women live in echo chambers
amongst women so women can sit amongst
other women and say yeah manifest him
girl you know you the law of attraction
is great like you don't worry he's
coming your
your your guy's coming it's like and men
are like
what the hell are they talking about
like
get on like because as men
when we want to do something we start
doing it we start like making the plans
to do something right and it's like if
you don't make plans to do something
and thinking you can like kind of wish
it into existence really and truly nine
times out of ten nothing actually gets
done
so this whole thing of
uh oh yeah i'll wish him into existence
and the law of attraction in the right
time blah blah blah
it's hard for men to hear that because
that table right there wasn't wished
into existence do you know what i mean
it was a man said i need to make a table
and i'm going to make a table i'm not
going to i'm not going to think about it
and think yeah it's going to say
i want to wish to be a millionaire into
existence right it's just like you have
to put plans into consideration if you
manifest it it could happen yeah but it
more than likely won't and like like i
come from a very my dad's very very
successful
but he got there by working 80 hours a
week my whole life i barely saw him it
wasn't by manifesting it
okay i mean have you read the secret
the book i've read it i've read it i've
actually read the secret it's a it's a
great book it's a great book and i think
it i thought that guy was a con artist
no i think i think no i swear to god it
came out he was a connor i think
essentially what the secret teaches is
good
i think essentially what because things
have to start in your mind before they
become
um
before they make it into fruition and i
get that that table started in
somebody's mind first before it became a
table it didn't just become a table
somebody thought about making it a table
and they said okay cool this is what's
gonna happen but they had to work to
actually get it done manifest something
and it helps you get there it also takes
working but obviously if you start
manifesting and telling yourself every
single day this will happen i can make
this happen it helps you actually
physically do it but it can help you but
but it it doesn't come with well yeah
of course you know you can't just say oh
i'm
going to be a billionaire tomorrow we'll
see when a lot of people a lot of people
think that when it comes to
manifestations yeah but obviously that's
not what what it is yeah yeah um it's
just that's what i when i first heard
about manifestation and all this
universe i was like so essentially
people are just writing down things and
saying this is gonna happen and just
sitting back and relaxing i was like you
still have to put in some work with it
um but i do have a question for the
women
you had
you had said something about um
being independent and if someone did
come to you
and
approach you for a relationship you'd be
scared when it comes to feminism do you
think that
it has taught women to be more
independent so when that
suitor that you've had in your mind for
so long does approach you you are so in
this independent mindset that
it it scares you because it has feminism
has taught you be independent be on your
own do you don't let a man do anything
for you think that's a hindrance to
women or it helps women in the end this
is a question for
everybody uh it goes both ways i guess
yeah
i think it's a bit in a limbo you know
when it comes to that um it's good to be
independent i think it's good to not
rely on a man because
if you're married and you don't have
kids and again we yesterday we were
talking about this like if the
relationship goes wrong and both they
get a divorce you know and then you
don't work you don't have an income
and then you're just like what you know
what the hell what am i gonna do you
know
uh so yeah it's good to be independent
it's good to make your own money but at
the same time
i mean if a man wants to provide and the
woman is fine to be at home you know
it's okay i don't judge but at the same
time society does everything i feel like
there's so many snowflakes out there
which is if you do if you if you choose
this they have something to say if you
choose that they have something to say
like who is like if you are with a rich
man you are a gold digger if you don't
work and he's rich you are a gold digger
well do you think that social if the if
the woman is rich and the man uh is not
you know like probably the woman is
older and he's younger oh you are a pimp
you know
there's always something to say there's
always something to judge these people i
feel like if we're less judgmental
judgmental and more understanding and
actually judge ourselves first and see
in the mirror and then huh judge you
know
i think it's just there's too many
snowflakes in this world i just feel
like
do you think sometimes that's like
social media though like you wouldn't
know 99 of people's opinions if it
wasn't for social media that's true yeah
you delete all social media tomorrow no
one will say anything to you not to your
face
i don't care for example i saw the our
live yesterday i saw on youtube i was
reading the comments they were a few
they were mean and i was like
i was actually you know eating and i was
like oh so good you know i don't give a
[ __ ] they even criticize credits i how
do you say this word criticized
criticized thank you beyonce come on
look at her huh can you do better than
her you know what i mean so who the [ __ ]
who are you but i think the question is
like do you really mean all they lost
but but i think you made me money every
word that he was saying
but i think the question is like do we
want to live our lives in a state of
fear like do we want to live and like a
fear of what people are going to say or
fear fear of a man leaving or fear like
we it's kind of no because what i've
found is girls that live their lives
like that they end up alone because
they're too afraid to let someone in
yeah and then and that's worse because
the the biggest increase in the homeless
population is older women you need two
incomes to retire for most women if
you're not making six figures or close
to it you need a second income otherwise
you'll be on the streets right
because um it takes one cancer diagnosis
to put us on the streets but feminism
keeps telling us in the u.s yeah
what in the us oh yeah maybe not right
in the uk
we got the national health service to
help us with that until until it runs
out
i mean national health service has been
going for a while in the uk you know i
mean like you you in the us
yeah like in the us you guys have got
like private insurance and stuff like
that so yeah right but the point is you
still you still need two incomes to
retire though
and
like
it's feminism tells you you don't you
don't need a man but we do
or a girl i don't discriminate you know
those people
i mean
but um
all human we need love we are you know
into that like we are yeah i think i
think human beings like human beings
need companionship yeah do you know what
i mean like um we currently live in a
time where you know whether you've been
on social media or not like it seems to
be like this gender war going on do you
know what i mean and it's like men hate
women women hate men blah blah blah and
it's like essentially that is only going
to lead to more loneliness essentially
do you know what i mean and it's just
like if you don't if you're not able to
find some kind of middle ground as men
and women then you're just all going to
be lonely you're going to be all going
to be lonely and hateful like come on
guys we need to kind of find some kind
of middle ground you know what i mean
and i